hey guys do you ever wonder what you do
if a gang of genetically evolved Apes
took over the planet
shattered social structure scarcity of
resources gun wielding apes on horseback
I'm talking about an eighth pocalypse
I'm Quinn Beswick welcome to my bunker
you're watching disaster school today's
lesson eight take over on disaster
school we look at pop culture's most
deadly events in film and TV and we
figure out if they did happen how would
you survive
dawn of the Planet of the Apes so a
virus wipes out a majority of the human
race while simultaneously creating these
genetically evolved Apes holy
sorry how would you survive in a
post-apocalyptic world I talked to a
sociologist scientist and a survivalist
a lot of monkey and ape species already
used tools just maybe not the kinds of
tools we use if they were really clever
in the movie they should have had the
chimp riding along firing two
machineguns with its hands and two
machineguns with its feet because its
feet are just like hands I mean now that
would have been a very good effect
don't you think smart Apes crumbling
society how do you make this work I mean
everything we take for granted is
suddenly gone the source of food the
clean water I'd want to have a secure
place to rest my body
okay so shelter like a bunker so the
idea that you're gonna stay in a bunker
for a year is ludicrous god I was so
sure about this bunker if you're in a
bunker you're in one spot you're not
really moving you're hiding out you
don't want people to know where you're
at you've got food that's been stored
but it's not a sustainable solution what
about when this stuff runs out I
encourage everybody to have some basic
gear with you at all times
I always carry a knife or two certainly
a Swiss Army knife ratchet Clippers it
comes in handy for wood for bone for all
sorts of things solid magnesium it'll
last for thousands of lights and then
you get a spark and you ignite you're
tender and then twine putting a shelter
together for crossing a river I would
carry a canteen essentially that's my
basic kit so pack all that up identify
weigh out with a group the chances of
both individual as well as group
survival are much greater if you have
skilled people in your team and you're
the kind of person that people like to
be around you're gonna find the things
that you need well at least there's one
thing we can all agree on avoid the Apes
what often aggression is non-contact
it's just threatening postures friendly
Apes I'm not buying it if you have an
unexpected encounter with an ape here
are some things to remember signs that
monkeys feel threatened include what's
called a fear premise and it looks like
a smile but it's more an anxiety and
fearful behavior they might written back
and making direct eye contact is a
threat they may you know mate or
defecate sometimes they'll freeze
they'll just become motionless smiling
defecating and freezing sounds like my
grandmother after three white wine
spritzers I'm just kidding she's dead
lip smacking is the behavior that
monkeys do to each other often after a
bite it's a rapid movement of the lips
or something like to show they're not a
threat they may alarm call to each other
oh if they call for backup your fault if
I came across an ape what I would do I
would drop my head I would put my hands
up
I would waddle over to him reach out
snaps neck if I were to come across a
group of primates avoid eye contact to
try to make myself smile and then I only
believe okay fine listen to her for
those of you who want to coexist with
the Apes that is totally your choice the
best way would be to go for cooperation
one of the things that humans do that
chimpanzees don't but could if they were
intelligent F is teaching and learning
so by demonstrating that you can provide
advantages coexistence would be possible
if both were mutually beneficial to each
other okay we learned a lot today so
let's recap don't be a dick have a pact
avoid the Apes if you meet the Apes
teach them something that's it for this
episode of disaster school be sure to
share this video with the people you
like so we can all survive the
apocalypse but don't share it with the
people you don't like cuz they will
weigh us down
hashtag disaster school and don't forget
to subscribe to the wired Channel
you
[Music]